مرحبًا بكم في مركز
فنون الدمى أنا جيل الوطنية للحكم ، مدير المتحف
أود أن
اصطحبكم إلى متحف عوالم العرائس وأريكم
ما لدينا هنا حتى يكون معرضنا
العالمي رائعًا لأنه يوضح كيف أن
التقاليد من  في جميع أنحاء العالم و
Cincy هذه الفوضى وما هو عظيم
في المعرض ليس فقط إظهار
هذه الاختلافات في الدمى حول
العالم لأوجه التشابه في الدمى
حول العالم وهذا يسلط الضوء على
أمريكا الجنوبية وأمريكا الشمالية التي قد لا
تعرفها ولكن توقف عن الحركة  هو في الواقع نوع
من الدمى ، هذا هو قسمنا الأوروبي
لذلك لدينا الكثير من
تقاليد العرائس الرائعة من
قارة إفريقيا وكلها مجمعة هنا
معًا وبعد ذلك عندما ننتقل هنا
لدينا دمى من The Lion King في
برودواي  الدمى الأفريقية
ولدينا دمى الظل والكثير من
الأشياء الرائعة هنا كلها تسلط الضوء
على أهمية الحيوانات كجزء من الدمى بينما ننتقل
إلى آسيا ، هناك الكثير من الأشياء الرائعة.
نحن على وشك الدخول إلى
مجموعة Jim Henson في مركز
ساحات العرائس وفي عام 2007
أعلنت عائلة Jim Henson أننا
سنصبح موطنًا لأكبر مجموعة في العالم
من دمى Jim Henson الآن ،
يعرف الكثير من الناس Jim Henson لـ Kermit
فارغ والدمية الأخرى لكنه لم يكن
مفروشًا في القلب وقد
جرب حقًا جميع أنواع
الأشياء المختلفة وما هو مميز
وفريد حقًا في مجموعتنا هنا هو أن
ا لا نمتلك تلك الدمى الشهيرة فح
ب ، بل نعرض جميع أنواع أع
اله و  يمكنك حقًا أن ترى كيف
كان مبدعًا ومبدعًا ، فهذه
إعادة إنشاء لورشة العمل وهذا مكان رائع حقًا
لأنه يمنحنا فرصة
لعرض بعض عناصر المجموعة
التي لا تتناسب بالضرورة
مع أحد  مناطق العرض الخاصة بنا كما أنها
تمنحنا فرصة
لإظهار الأدوات والأشياء التي استخدمها الأشخاص في
صنع الدمى المتحركة
[الموسيقى
] وبالطبع الجميع يعرف السماح
ونحن سعداء جدًا  أنه هنا أيضًا
لدينا الآنسة Piggy من Muppet Treasure
Island والكثير من الدمى المتحركة من
Muppet Treasure Island بالإضافة إلى الكثير
من أصدقائك من Muppet Show ، لذا
فقد مررنا للتو بعوالم
متحف الدمى ولدينا أيضًا واحدة
معرض خاص لمدة عام ولدينا أيضًا
برامج تعليمية وعروض عرائس
حية نأمل أن
تأتي وتراها ولكن إذا لم تتمكن من الحضور
إلى المركز ، فلدينا برنامج رائع حقًا
للتعلم عن بعد يتيح
لنا التواصل مع الناس جميعًا
لقد كان من دواعي سروري حول العالم أن
تكون قد استمتعت بجولتك ويرجى
القدوم ورؤيتنا هنا في ميدتاون أتلانتا
[موسيقى]